Aaron Sorkin is one of Hollywood's most
sought-after writers the Oscar winners
signature sharp dialogue is behind hit
movies like a few good men the social
network and Moneyball plus TV dramas
like The West Wing and the newsroom
Sorkin is making his debut as a director
in Molly's game it stars Jessica
Chastain and Idris Elba Sorkin wrote the
script based on the real-life Molly
bloom she became an FBI target for
hosting one of the most exclusive
high-stakes poker games
Chastain portrays bloom in the movie
Elba plays her defense attorney in this
clip bloom tells him why she refuses to
give up her famous roster of players and
ruin her reputation for immunity
I threw four people under the bus for
$35,000 Charlie I noticed she kept that
out of your speech the prosecutor I took
advantage of gambling addicts Donny
Silverman my brilliant find he lost
moved to Florida got a job as a
substitute teacher then hanged and
parlin Eustace is in jail in Nevada
wishing he was but that's not why I'm
saying no you're not saying no I was
named after my great-grandmother I don't
care Molly you understand nobody gives
you about your goodness
why because I have left because it's my
name and Aaron Sorkin welcome back to
CBS this morning great to be here we
were all surprised to learn that with
everything that you've done over the
years you had never directed a
television show or a film that's right
would I write something I always want
the best possible director for that
piece to direct it and that's never been
me why is he well I didn't write this
with the intention of directing it but
when I turned in the first draft the
producers felt that I was the best want
to direct it and it took a few weeks of
encouragement from directors I've worked
with who felt that I should direct it
but in the end the reason why I directed
it is this there are a lot of shiny
objects in this story and there's a
natural gravitation
pull toward them the glamour the
decadence the money the poker and the
Hollywood bold face names and I had
always wanted to tell a story set
against the backdrop of those things but
focus on the larger much more emotional
and much more complex and nuanced story
about Molly bloom herself
I loved her character but not only did
you direct I want to fall upon that for
a second you're directing Kevin Costner
go by the way has won the Academy Award
for Dances with Wolves to me that's like
cooking for Julia Child do that I was
already at maximum fear and intimidation
level and then Kevin Costner came along
and said that he wanted to play the role
of Molly's father and he's fantastic
excuse me but the idea of directing
Kevin was certainly daunting he would
remind me from time to time that when he
made his directorial debut with Dances
with Wolves he had to worry about which
direction 5,000 Buffalo were going to
run everyone swap listen he was very
encouraging and continues to be he'll
text me every few days you know he would
text me of a few days during
post-production saying I know you're
gonna worry about this but don't worry
about that you text me this morning
saying okay you're doing CBS this
morning here's what Gail's going to ask
he's great but yes we were shooting we
were on a mountain molly was an
olympic-class skier and the whole movie
begins when she comes a hundred yards
from making the US Olympic team but both
literally and metaphorically trips over
a stick and Kevin had he knew that I had
a shot tracking him running through the
crowd trying to make it to Molly who's
taking a terrible fall she's she's
unconscious and he said uh you know if
you want you you can you've got you're
tracking me you can just hand off to the
commentators right up there and it's a
shot I hadn't thought of and I said to
everybody gather round Kevin had a
really good idea for a shot oh we're
gonna do this and later on Kevin kind of
took me aside and said you know you
don't have to give me credit for the
shot it's C this is your movie it's yeah
so Kevin Costner in addition to being as
talented
is he is is the nicest person in the
world if the fact is that this whole
movie was just a triumph of
collaboration I was surrounded by great
people beginning and ending with Jessica
who was such a phenomenal partner on the
set she was your first choice for this
this role how did your first meeting
with her go our first meeting was great
I didn't it wasn't an audition for
Jessica I already knew you know from her
body of work that that she was who I
wanted I was going to this meeting to
try to discover if this actress who has
been directed by Ridley Scott and
Kathryn Bigelow and Terrence Malick
Ellen would be willing to take directs
you from a first-time director or would
I be taking direction from her and about
three minutes into the meeting she
leaned in and said listen this meeting
is stupid you should just give me the
part and I said yeah you're right okay
Jessica you cannot fake funny and you
cannot fake smart there are things look
at an actor can't act an actor can't act
smart they can't act funny they can't
act strong they can act tough which is
an affectation that you use if you're
not strong but Jessica has those things
in her bloodstream brings them with her
too she said she said that there was a
lot of fun on the set and and that she
was surprised to learn about your
excellent singing voice well I believe
that that she is saying that as a form
of retribution well are you singing I'm
a big believer in morale on the set so
there was some Gilbert and Sullivan but
then there was also this thing that
began on and I think day three of the
shoot you know you when you're filming a
movie you shoot one side of the scene
yeah and then you turn around and you
shoot the other side of the scene so
when when we would rap out on on one
side you know I'd say okay cut that's
great print that one
now let's turn around and as soon as I
said turn around
Jessica would start singing turn around
it happened every day including on our
last night of shooting which is the
scene where we shot in Central Park it's
a big scene between Costner and and
Jessica we shot it all night long and I
was walking by the park bench where
where Jessica and Kevin were kind of
getting themselves ready and I hear
Kevin Costner singing time how the whole
thing it had just trickled through the
entire show great aaron sorkin thank you
Molly's getting like theaters Christmas
Day and nationwide on January 5th